Okay,
so that's a big mistake that the
postmodernist made.
That's not trivial.
That's a big mistake,
but it's not the only one.
Well,
here's another one.
They don't like inequality.
Well,
who does?
I'm against poverty.
You know,
that's like classic protest sign.
It's like,
really?
It's like I'm against torture.
It's like it's so obvious.
You don't get any Brownie points for
being against poverty.
No one in their right mind is for
poverty.
You know,
you ever watched the simpsons?
You ever see the Republican Party in the
simpsons,
they all meet in an old haunted castle
at night with like lightning bolts going
off and there's a vampire and a crazy
texts and then even the Simpson
Republicans don't sit around in the
haunted tower at midnight saying,
Hey,
we need more poverty.
Here's an interesting thing.
So one of the postmodernists claims is
that diversity is necessary and they
make it racial and they make it sexual.
They may get ethnic and all of that.
That's actually technically incorrect by
the way,
because I study individual differences.
So those are the differences between
people.
I know the literature.
So you know about James Damore memo
right from Google.
He wrote that partly because he was
watching my videos,
which is why he wanted me to interview
him and I'm a believer that there are
biological differences in temperament
between men and women apart from the
other obvious differences and that
they're actually not trivial
and that they maximizing the societies
that have the most have moved farthest
to producing egalitarian states,
the Scandinavian countries,
and that.
The reason for that is that there's two
reasons why men and women,
different temperament.
One is biological and the other is
environmental,
and if you remove the environmental
variation,
which you do,
if you make the state egalitarian,
you maximize the genetic variation and
that's been demonstrated in the
scientific literature over about four
decades and no one wanted it or hope for
it and they weren't biased and looking
for it because that was exactly the
opposite of what social scientists
wanted to find.
Because social scientists lean heavily
to the left and what they wanted to find
was you flatten out the state so that
everyone has equal opportunity and the
differences between people disappear.
That is not what happened.
The opposite happened that wasn't wrong
and no one was happy about it and no
one's happy about it.
Now you can actually tell when you've
discovered something in the social
science because you're not happy about
it,
but
if you take,
let's say there's a big difference
between men and women in terms of trait,
agreeableness,
compassion and politeness on average,
women are more than men and the
difference is approximately this.
If you take random pairs of men and
women out of the population,
let's say you had to make a back on who
was more agreeable.
If you bet that it was the woman,
you'd be right 60 percent of the time.
Well,
that's not that much.
It means you'd be wrong.
Forty percent of the time.
That's almost 50 percent of the time.
So this is a big difference by social
science standards,
but that's the magnitude of the
difference.
There are some differences that are
bigger,
like the difference between men and
women's interest in people versus things
is actually bigger than that.
That's the biggest difference we know,
but it's a big difference.
Let's say the agreeable this difference,
but still they the shared attributes of
men and women far outweigh the
attributes that differentiate them
because you could ask are there more
differences with any groups or between
them?
Now the postmodern answer to that is
between them.
That's why you need diversity by group,
right?
That's why you need different races.
That's why you need different
ethnicities and sexual preferences and
all of that.
Well,
that's wrong.
There's moral difference within the
groups than there is between them.
You don't get diversity by crossing the
groups.
You get diversity by,
by selecting across individuals.
In fact,
the idea that there is more differences
between groups said there is between
individuals is actually the fundamental
racist idea.
It's the fundamental racist idea,
which is,
well,
let's say you're Asian Oriental to use
the old word to discriminate the one
type of Asian say from the other.
You're so different from me that there's
no overlap between our groups and you're
also so different and there's so little
difference within your group that now
that I know that you're not me,
you're not one of mine.
I actually know what you're like,
no,
technically that's incorrect.
That's wrong.
That isn't how you get diversity.
Now,
diversity is actually necessary because
people differ in intelligence and a
different temperament and the different
skills and so you actually need
diversity because otherwise you can't
take advantage of all those differences,
so you need diversity,
but you need genuine diversity and like
what would genuine diversity mean?
If you're trying to put together a work
team,
you want enough,
you want people have sufficient
diversity so that they more or less so
that you gathered together the
appropriate talent to produce the
implement that's necessary to work
properly in the world.
That's a competence marker because
otherwise your business is going to fail
and so the proper diversity with regards
to employment is the diversity that
meets the requirements of the business
essentially.
Obviously that's why you try to hire
people carefully and not randomly.
Let's say third year our first errors.
There's only a finite number of valid
interpretation.
Second error is that there are real
differences between groups of people,
but there's more differences within the
groups.
Then between them.
Third Difference is social status and
payment,
especially in a free democratic
capitalist society is based more on
competence than on
power.
In fact,
we would say that when a person in a
hierarchy starts to act like their
position,
entitles them to power,
then that hierarchy has become corrupt.
Harvey Weinstein is a good example of
that.
I'm serious.
It's like he aksed acted like a tyrant.
What happened to him?
It's not good,
not good for him.
What he did was not good,
but it's an indication.
It's revealed.
It's an indication that that misuse,
so he's competent,
fine.
He gets to have position because we need
people who are competent,
but that doesn't mean you get to turn
into a tyrant.
If you turn it into a tyrant,
then that overshadows your competence
and you go.
That's the definition of a functioning
state and our state essentially
functioned.
It's not perfect,
that's for sure,
but compared to what?
That's the issue compared to your
hypothetical Marxist Utopia,
while compared to your hypothetical
Marxist Utopia.
I mean,
we're living in Auschwitz,
but your but your actual Marxist utopia
is indistinguishable from Auschwitz,
so we're not listening to that
comparison.
We're going to take a look at what we
have and we're going to compare it to
other places that actually existed in
time and geographically and by those
criteria.
It's like,
is there another time you'd rather live
is another place you'd rather live,
I mean a real place and in real time,
have you want to live back in 18,
95.
Even in the western world where the
average person lived on less than a
dollar a day.
In today's money,
you want to live like those coal miners
like the answer to that is no.
If you have any sense,
you should have some gratitude.
That's another problem with the
postmodern neo Marxists like zero,
zero,
zero gratitude.
It's all,
oh my God,
I'm more pressed.
Of course you're oppressed,
but you're not impressed by the
Patriarchy for God's sake.
So you have status in the hierarchy.
You might say,
well,
that's like a reward to your a high
status person.
It's a reward.
That reward should be shared equally.
It's like a badge of merit that you get.
It's a privilege.
It's not the reason that in a capitalist
society,
filthy selfish capitalists put you in
the position so they can extract maximum
productivity from you and that's exactly
why you're there.
You get paid,
you get paid,
so you keep working.
Why do we want you to work?
Because your work is actually valuable
to us and so we're going to pay you so
you don't quit.
It's not a reward because you're a good
guy.
It's not a privilege.
That's not what it is.
You don't hand those things out like
merit badges.
That's not how it works.
The society is setup on selfish
principles.
We pay people who are competent so they
won't stop striving because we want what
they can produce.
So you don't just distribute that like
like it's a gift.
It's not a gift.
It's not a gift at all.
So that's another place where they're
wrong.
Social Status and payment is the
consequence of the selfish desire of
individuals and the group to extract
resources of intellect,
creativity,
and industriousness from those who
possess them in excess.
Now,
of course,
it's not 100 percent like that.
There's the incompetent people who rise
to the top.
You can fool people and you can
manipulate them and you can act like a
tyrant and you know,
we might say maybe the system is like 30
percent warped,
something like that.
It's not much more than that because we
can account for people's success across
life by looking at their individual
differences,
intelligence comp,
conscientiousness,
emotional stability,
creativity.
We can do a pretty good job of
predicting their trajectory.
So there's error,
some of its health,
right?
Because sometimes you've got what you
need,
but you get cut off at the knees or your
family members do or you know,
some tragic thing befalls you.
There's a randomness in the system that
accounts for a fair bit of it and then
there's a certain amount of corruption.
Fair enough,
but not so much that the lights go off.